2018 عضوا في مجلس النواب الامريكي لصالح
استبعاد النائبه عن الحزب الديمقراطي
الهان عمر من لجنه شؤون الخارجيه بسبب
انتقاداتها السابقه لاسرائيل مقابل 211
صوتا معارضا وقال رئيسه مجلس النواب كذا
مكارسي بعد التصويت انه تم استبعاد
النائبه من لجنه شؤون الخارجيه فقط وليس
من اللجان الاخرى بسبب تعليقاتها المعاديه
للساميه من جهته وصف زعيم الاقليه في مجلس
النواب حكيم جفري التصويت بانه انتقام
سياسي من النائبه على الاخطاء التي
ارتكبتها قبل اربع سنوات وقال انها خضعت
للمساءله واعتذرت
معنى من واشنطن مراسل والجزيره محمد
الاحمد محمد ماذا في تفاصيل هذا التصويت
وردود الفعل عليها
نعمل في الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب اطاحوا
عمليا بالنائبه الهام عمر من لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه في المجلس وهي واحده من اللجان
النافذه في المجلس وذلك ردا على اتهامات
لها
بالاجلاء بتصريحات سابقه خاصه في عام 2019
بالتحديد وصفات بانها منتقده لاسرائيل
ووصفها اخرون بانها تندرج في اطار معاداه
الساميه الهام عمر كانت قد اعتدرت عن تلك
التصريحات الديمقراطيون ايضا
كانوا قد وجهوا لها انتقادات لكن تم يعني
تفهم ذلك الموقف واعتذرت عن تلك التصريحات
لكنها تستخدم اليوم في الاطاحه عمليا
بالهان عمر من هذه
اللجنه التي خدمت فيها لسنوات الهام عمر
ردت على هذا القرار بانه يندرج في اطار
الاستهداف الشخصي السياسي باعتبارها انها
اول نائبه مسلمه من اصول افريقيه من
الصومال حيث تمثل احدى الدوائر الانتخابيه
في ولايه مينيسوتا البيت الابيض
انتقد هذا القرار ودافع عن الهان عمر وعن
شخصيه الهان عمر وكذلك حكيم
الاقليه الديمقراطيه في المجلس الذي وضع
هذا القرار بانه يندرج في اطار الانتقام
السياسي كيفن رئيس مجلس النواب نفى تلك
الاتهامات وقال بان هذا القرار ياتي نظرا
لحساسيه
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في المجلس وبان من
يمثلون هذه اللجنه يجب ان يتحلوا عمليا
بالمسؤوليه عند الابلاء بهذه التصريحات
لكن كثيرين يعتبرون ان قرار كيفن ماكرتي
ياتي استجابه وارضاء للجناح اليميني داخل
الحزب الذي ساهم في انتخابه رئيسا من خلال
استهداف الهان عمر وقبلها استهد الاخرين
ينظر اليهم من الجانب الجمهوري بانها
شخصيات متورطه في الاستهداف السياسي ضد
الجمهوريين ومن بينهم ادم شيف الرئيس
السابق للجنه المخابرات في مجلس النواب
الذي تمت الاطاحه به ايضا من عضويه اللجنه
من طرف الجمهوريين ايضا
السياق اسرائيل فيما يتعلق بالتجاذب
السياسي بين الحزبين الديمقراطيين تاريخيا
يعني مدافعون عن اسرائيل بشكل كبير في
السنوات الاخيره ظهرت بعض الاصوات خاصه من
الديمقراطيين من الجناح التقدمي المنتقده
لاسرائيل ومن بينها الهام عمر وكذلك رشيد
الطيب وبالتالي ينظر ايضا الى هذا القرار
انه محاوله من كبر مكارم لارضاء الجناح
اليمين داخل الحزب وبالمقابل للاستماله
اصوات الناخبين اليهود وايضا لكسب الدعم
من اللوبي الاسرائيلي واليهودي النافذ في
البلاد وبالتالي تقرا هذه الخطوه على انها
تندرج في اطار الصراع السياسي بين الحجبين
الحزبين مؤشر ايضا على حجم الاستقطاب
السياسي بين الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين لكن
عمليا الهان عمر بالرغم من انها لن تكون
عضوا في لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه ستواصل
مهمتها كعضوى في لجان اخرى اقل اهميه وفي
محاوله ايضا
لتجاوز
تلك التصريحات التي ادلت بها انضمت الى
عدد من الديمقراطيين في التوقي على مشروع
قرار يعتبر اسرائيل حليف شرعي واساسي
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده ويودين ذلك
القرار ايضا معاداه الساميه وهي وهو موقف
ايضا يتفق مع تصريحات سابقه لها اشارت
فيها الى انها تعتذر عن تلك التصريحات
انها يجب ان تتحلى بالمسؤوليه اكثر وبانها
تعلمت في الواقع من تلك التصريحات في
كيفيه ممارسه السياسه في
الكونجرس نعم محمد احمد مراسلنا من واشنطن